hello my name is Charles Joseph McDonald
but you can call me Charlie I'm 20 years
old and I make stuff and I put it on the
Internet this is sort of embarrassing
but I've never really had a proper job I
started making videos on YouTube when I
was meant to be revising for exams and
then just didn't really stop making
videos and then at some point Google
started paying me to make those videos
and then later I realised that it was my
job I just sort of fell into it really
you can imagine me sort of like an alien
abductee who's been picked up off of the
surface of earth and then plunked onto a
planet made out of ice cream
I didn't addint planned for it to happen
it's sort of confusing but you know it's
nice tasty I also imparted my living
from making and releasing music which is
weird to me because I don't think I'm a
particularly amazing musician I mean I'm
I'm alright I just don't take it very
seriously
case in point probably my most serious
musical project is the band that I'm in
the play songs about the TV show Doctor
Who so there you go I don't pretend to
try and be anything resembling like a
serious musician which probably works
out in my favor I just do it because
it's fun and I know I I guess some
people appreciate the fun this of it I
currently have a bunch of people
watching me on the internet like a nice
a nice bunch there are statistics and
things on my youtube channel but I try
to avoid looking at them because I have
in the past just become obsessed with
like numbers going up and down and I'm
now comfortable just to have a nice
bunch that's fine and that way of
thinking extends to how I make my videos
as well I don't like to think of it like
a sea of eyeballs that I need to trick
into liking my video or subscribing to
my channel or maybe leave me a comment
telling me your favorite type of shampoo
or whatever I just try to make good
stuff that's that's my thing I try to
make good stuff and I have faith that if
the stuff I make is actually good then
the rest of that stuff will come with it
regardless and I also like to think of
making these videos just for you because
you aren't a sea of eyeballs or
thousands of people or a community
you're just a person one normal actual
person sitting in front of their
computer or whatever watching this and I
think thinking about you as anything
other than just what you are a person
watching me some guy on the internet
makes this less personal and I like it
when it's personal it's like a
conversation a very one-sided
conversation as a result of doing this
internet thing and being in the public
eye I have over the years been contacts
by various manager e-business e
television e people wanting their slice
of the Charlie pie you know can't blame
them it's a it's a tasty pie apple pie
probably I've had some interesting
experiences to say the least I actually
had a manager for about two years that I
never told you about rude of me the same
people that used to manage Simon Cowell
also used to manage me whatever managing
is I've had a girl presenting in
television like scenarios before which
has been alright overall but I much
prefer being able to just make my own
stuff I can't get comfortable reading
someone else's script and pretending to
be myself it's very very odd I had a
similar experience with music as well I
was in this band slash collective type
thing with some friends but we basically
tried to do more mainstream popping
music and you know in its own right it
was I guess successful we had a manager
and we were you know we almost got into
the charts and we were interviewed in
newspapers as well but it just wasn't I
just didn't get all of it it just wasn't
fun and I think that's the key thing for
me really it has to be fun I figure if
it's not fun then I'm not gonna want to
put in the extra effort to make it as
good as it needs to be it's just a
necessity fun is a necessity nowadays
I'm just hanging out on my own I don't
have any kind of formal management or
anything I'm just doing whatever the
hell I want just making videos on the
internet and stuff and I've never been
happier so take that mainstream
entertainment industry yeah showed you
didn't I so that's me pretty much me as
of Sunday the 8th of May at 12:07 so yay
hopefully I'll see you around adios can
I hit myself in the eye there it was
fine you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool